good the MTV VMAs genius moments of all
time plus a look back at video Vanguard
honoree J Lo's best music video guys
grab your Sony's and a bowl of popcorn
because the shadiest awards show on TV
is back the MTV Video Music Awards and
I've been Loki obsessed with the VMA
since I was a kid
mainly because if history has taught us
anything the celebrity claws come out
around those moon men and I'm here for
it
Tommy look back on these iconic VMA
moments is our each hemline other
dezirae movies any thanks so much for
having us because you're also a fellow
VMA fangirl I know you are yes I am
that's right so let's get right to what
is your favorite shadiest V M a moment
of Alton okay well there have been so
many but I would have to say in 2015
when Miley Cyrus hosted Nicki Minaj came
on stage to accept an award and she gave
us this iconic shade and now back to
this [ __ ] that had a lot to say about
me to of a Dana breath Miley what's good
oh god I remember thinking like is this
stage was this real but I feel like
everything Nikki does is real yeah it
felt real I just love that she's using
this moment there she just weren't an
award to like call out someone who
called her out prior you know I mean
that's what the VMAs all does that say
exactly a Nikki a plain either and she
may have but she may be out for blood
this year too because not only should
performing at this year's VMAs but cardi
B is also opening the show and they've
had their own weird his channel a very
interesting friendly rivalry right and
today guys she actually dragged Travis
Scott and Kylie Jenner after Travis's
album astral world beat her record Queen
for the top of the Billboard 200 charts
she tweeted I put my blood sweat and
tears and writing a dope album only for
Travis Scott to have Kylie Jenner post a
tour pass telling people to come see her
and stormy lol
I'm actually laughing okay I'm actually
laughing honey I'm laughing too and
Nicki Minaj has not been holding back so
she released Queen and tonight is her
night I don't think he's gonna hold back
when she's performing at all yeah and in
the seating charts that we got a sneak
peek guy
Travis and Nikki are actually sitting
very close to the right there nikki is
sitting right in front of Travis and
Kylie so hopefully it's all tea no shade
yes I do feel like she's just kind of
getting a little route of them I don't
think it's that serious because she even
says she's laughing guys she's funny but
I am kind of with Nikki on this one
though cuz I mean Kylie saying like I'm
bringing stormy along for the tour Mike
and I solo lines and like Travis is
selling Asscher rolled with every ticket
purchase and the markets all a little
sketchy it's the end plus let's not
forget Kylie has a huge followings yes
nikki has a point there she's giving me
Kanye vibes how hard she's repping her
record though and I'm loving it I love
it too don't be quiet exactly louder get
louder drone now speaking of Kanye we
got to go to my favorite shady moments
in da history who can forget when a
young Kanye West stormed the stage for a
young Taylor Swift as she accepted her
very first VMA and then he gave us this
iconic one I'm really happy for you imma
let you finish but Beyonce had one of
the best videos of all time
poor Beyonce I know I watch that and I
still it's still cringe-worthy yeah I
feel for Taylor in that mom now but I
mean that moment is kind of what made
the VMAs what it is today like back in
the day it was all about the crazy
fashion on the carpet which it still is
yeah but the shady moments is what we
look out for now know what I'm gonna say
it also kind of made Taylor Swift I'm
sorry smell come for me single ladies
was the best video of all time but you
know what she got her moving up there
that I show things to Beyonce's that's
true caliber my alliance lines all right
so the next one when you guys were gonna
fall under unintentional shade but we'll
still never forget it the year 2003 the
culprits Britney Madonna and Christina
and the kiss scene around the world
[Music]
iconic it's so good it's really good hey
you know what the shade though is not
courtesy of any of the women on that
stage the shot comes courtesy of those
beat me producers the director in that
control room saying cut to Justin yeah
and just show Britney and Madonna that's
the thing about your saying oh well
that's the problem right Britney and
Justin just split so they were really
smart on cutting to Justin but Justina
got the boot and guess which pop singer
got the photo op in that moment it was
Britney Britney that's why she D but I
love I know we live we live it we live
for it
Oh like we met you guys every year the
VMAs turn out moments like that and the
ones that we're talking about the next
day and this year we're predicting this
will come courtesy of Jennifer Lopez yes
so that's right JLo is taking home the
big award of the night the Michael
Jackson video Vanguard Award and
additionally she will be returning to
the stage for a performance for the
first time since 2000 and watched any I
was shocked learning this because I feel
like she's one of those performers that
would be on every award show of 100
percent cause she doesn't know woman you
know like the VMAs live for moments like
that you know like when she perform her
jaw ruin oh yeah the one but you guys as
we know jenny has also been in the game
for 20 years with about damn time she's
getting a recognition like this and I
want to talk to you about like what are
some of her most memorable videos oh
there's so many cuz like you said 20
years in the spotlight that's a big deal
but to kick things off I'd like to do my
personal favorite of hers I'm real remix
with ja Rule
[Music]
I mean I'm sure you can say the same but
I still remember to this day like coming
off the bus and seeing that on TRL for
the very first time and then like every
girl my age begging my mom to give me a
pair of those juicy sweaty little moment
that is a really cool video and one of
her fades - I remember she was saying
that people were surprised as she
decided to rock that pink juic so yeah
it was her idea exactly and like
everyone is bringing in high fashion
looks and she's like nope I'm making
this decision we're going with it and I
think it's safe to say we're all very
happy she did it's so true alright one
of my favorite videos JLo videos of all
time Jenny from the block hey Denny from
the block oh my god yes that works so
well but that one hat is full with
everything I mean it's like contacts
like are like at the time she was did
we've been using that word a lot but
that's Kayla for you she was dating Ben
Affleck at the time he's in that video
she takes it back to her roots on sex
and in New York in the Bronx like yeah
it's so awesome and that song I think is
gonna follow her everywhere oh yeah and
even people that don't necessarily you
know know Jennifer Lopez as much as we
do and they're fangirling right now they
know who Jenny from the bloggers they
know she's from the Bronx oh man
this is legendary I what's another one
of your favorites okay well something I
love about all Jennifer Lopez music
videos is the fact that we can almost
always expect a dance break she is the
queen of those dance breaks I love a
good JLo dance and with get right I mean
this was one of the most epic dance
breaks we've ever seen pool can ever
forget her in these like amazing silver
pants she has the came she's dancing
around right yeah on top of that she
played seven other characters in this
video in addition to just being Jennifer
Lopez her dance moves were killer but so
were her ABS yeah it's like that body
that's another thing we can expect from
jail this is the JLo block even tonight
in her performance you know she's gonna
be rocking the crop top of some Sun I'm
predicting multiple outfits yes but she
would take it to one of her more recent
videos - let's do it
I think proving that she's not going
anywhere she's still the fierce and
fabulous Jenny from the block that we
all fell in love with those years ago
she released what I think is one of her
best music videos of all time
narrow was DJ Khaled and cardi B just
this year again this year dance break
costume body like it had it all so good
and it's nominated this year yes it's
gotten two nominations for best
collaboration and best Latin isn't that
wild that she is getting a career
achievement award but also still
nominated for the stuff she's putting on
right yes that's right JLo Lopez all
right well I can't wait to see your
performance we already know she's gonna
turn it out tonight
that's gonna be fun the VMAs of course
air tonight on MTV at 9 p.m. and I'll be
live tomorrow 12:15 pacific for a live
recap of the night's performances
fashion then yes - shadeija so shady
moments are you guys thanks for watching
we'll see you tomorrow
[Music]